-Guys, this is exciting.
I'm about to bring out a
very special guest.
He's a groundbreaking
digital artist
whose works have
sold for over $100 million.
He's currently working on
a project called "Everydays,"
where he's been making one piece
of digital art every single day.
And yesterday marked
the 15th anniversary
of when he first started.
Here to talk about it,
give it up for Beeple,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It's nice to see you. Beeple.
-Hey.
-Thank you for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
-I want to talk to you about
"Everydays,"
this project "Everydays."
Yesterday was the
15th anniversary of it
to when you first started it.
What was your goal when you
started this 15 years ago?
-Yeah, it started
on May 1, 2007.
So it's been a sec here.
But I just wanted to get better.
And I started out
doing drawings,
and they were not very good.
And I wanted to
get better at it,
and that's why
I'm still doing it today.
I still really
want to get better.
-We have your first one.
-Alright, okay.
-This is your first one
that you've done there.
Yeah, that's "Uber Jay."
-See? There you go.
I mean, you can see
why I would want to improve.
-Yeah. I think that's fine.
I mean, and then, that's that,
but then here's the one
you did yesterday.
Ooh.
-Slightly better.
-Well, see?
Look at the reaction
from the audience.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You go from "Uber Jay" --
Uber Jay, by the way,
was that your uncle?
-Uncle Jim, yeah.
He's gotten some airtime here.
-Yeah, he has some airtime here.
But, so, yeah,
you have been getting better
and doing crazier stuff.
Well, you haven't made
today's drawing yet.
-I have not.
-And this is an idea that we had
last time we saw each other,
and I go,
"Can we pull this off?"
Tonight, you're going to create
it for us during the show.
-Yep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, how does this work?
How can we help?
Do you have a screen?
What do you have? A light pen?
Do you have a...
-So, I do have
a computer back there.
And I start from scratch
each day.
But what I do have is, I have a
3-D model of your head
that was made to me
by my buddy Raf, and --
-Do I know Raf?
-Raf Grassetti.
-Is Raf a fan of mine?
-He's a fan. He's a fan.
-Okay, good.
-Yeah.
And, so, we've got a 3-D model
and we've got all these
different sort of, like, objects
that we can use to kind of,
like, fill out the scene.
So it's kind of like
having a bunch of toys
that we can kind of, like,
place to, like, make a picture.
So, I was actually looking for
you to kind of, like,
come up with some sort of, like,
suggestions of what
you think
the picture should be today.
-Well, it's "The Tonight Show."
We make a lot of people laugh.
We -- Also, a lot of people
fall asleep to our show.
-Okay. We'll see if we can
put that into the picture.
-Our logo is the moon,
the "Tonight Show" moon.
So you could do something
on the moon, maybe.
-Moon, people sleeping,
laughing.
-That kind of sums up our show.
-Your face.
-Yeah.
-My face.
Yeah, it kind of
sums up my face, yeah.
Yeah, or anything like that.
And, also, it's spring.
Anything else?
-Flowers.
-Flowers?
-Shout out things.
-Flowers!
-Flowers. Okay.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Did you say "mace"?
No, I don't know -- Mace?
What is that?
-The Roots!
-Jester, jester.
-A jester?
-Jester, okay.
-Ooh, interesting.
-Cherry blossoms, jester.
We got a couple things
to work with.
-Yeah, we got some things
to work with here.
-A couple things.
-Alright, perfect.
Now, so, when you do this,
how long does it normally take?
-It usually takes
about two hours.
-Okay, we don't have
that tonight.
-We do not have two hours.
-No.
-So you're just gonna go
and just get in there.
And we're going to be
checking in.
Okay, you have a room
with a thing.
If you need anything from me,
let me know, okay, bud?
-Okay, we got it?
-Alright, Beeple right there.
Good luck.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, Beeple's going off.
Go, go, go, go!
We're going to check in with him
throughout the show
and see how he's doing.
And then,
at the end of the show,
we're going to unveil Beeple's
latest "Everydays" piece.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Can't wait to see
what he comes up with.
♪♪
-♪ Unh ♪
♪ Legendary, hard-workin' ♪
♪ Dance ♪
♪♪
-Welcome back.
Should we check in with
Beeple really quick
and just see -- Is he at work?
Beeple, are you -- Can you --
Yeah, you're at work.
Can you give us taste
of what it is or not really?
-Uh, I an give you a taste.
I don't if you want a taste --
-Alright, maybe I don't want
a taste right now.
Alright, hold on. Let's just go.
I'll start the show.
Here we go.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back, everybody.
We're joined by one of the most
innovative digital artists
out there, Beeple, right here.
Now, during the show,
you made a brand-new piece
of digital art for us.
How did it go, by the way?
-Well...
-Uh-oh.
-This is usually
a little quicker
than I'm used to working.
I haven't done that many pieces
on "The Tonight Show,"
so this is definitely
a little new for me.
-Yeah, well, I don't think
anyone's ever done this
on television before,
to make a brand-new
piece of art during the show,
so thank you for doing this.
Now, what are you going to
call this piece?
-Um...I don't know.
I'm going to be honest.
I just made it literally
like 10 minutes ago.
-Oh, yeah.
So, think about the name.
-We'll think about the name.
-Alright, yeah.
Now, before we pull this off
and reveal,
are we going to be friends
after this?
[ Laughter ]
-I think we will,
but I would like to point out,
you were the one that said
people sleep through the show.
I did not say that.
-No, no, eventually,
they go to sleep.
-Okay, okay.
Po-tay-to, po-tah-to.
It's what it is.
-Eventually, yeah.
Alright, here we go.
[ Drumroll ]
It is time for the big reveal.
In honor of the 15th anniversary
of his "Everydays" series,
here's Beeple's latest piece,
titled -- I don't know --
"Late Night Sleep."
I have no idea.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You got the people
sleeping in there.
-Hopefully they're sleeping.
Oh, my God. A giant head.
Dude, this is wild.
Well, you've got the moon
in there, though.
-We got the moon.
We got the cherry blossoms.
-You got the cherry blossoms.
-People sleeping.
-This is what people wanted.
-You're smiling.
-I am smiling. I love this.
Beeple, this is a work of art.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Congratulations.
I can't wait to see what you do
in the next 15 years.
There's Beeple right there.
Beeple.
-Thank you, guys. Thank you.
-My thanks to Norman Reedus,
Paula Pell, The Linda Lindas.
Beeple once again. I love it.